[Music]
daos and it stands for decentralized
autonomous organization
are
a kind of very interesting promising
still i would say flavor of the month
kind of organization
that operates on the blockchain
that is supposed to and when it works
well does
allow for collective
decision making
quote unquote from the bottom up
that is to say they do not have a
central authority in the middle they
don't have the centralized decision
maker that most constitutional systems
ordinarily do have they don't have as it
were a president or a prime minister and
they also don't have a hierarchical
system
where like a staff or a board of
directors
that's elected makes decisions about
where the assets of the organization
should be put
instead the idea is that everybody
collectively who's in the dao can vote
on how resources are going to be
allocated so they're kind of a strong
wisdom of crowds idea the idea is that
if the collective
makes the decisions the odds are better
that the collectivity will make good
decisions and that also tells you what
the value proposition is to invest in a
deo is in a way
to bet on the wisdom of the crowd and
not just the wisdom but on the
collective capacity of the crowd to work
together
and that's a fascinating bet
and you can see from that formulation
why it's very attractive and also why
it's a bit utopian and why some people
remain skeptical
of the capacities of daos to do all of
the different things that people hope
that they'll be able to do because again
talk about using history to predict the
future if you look at the history of
decentralized decision-making
organizations
they've often existed
guilds
some labor unions depending on how they
were organized they can do certain
things really well they can coordinate
certain things really well but there are
certain kinds of decision making that
historically are really hard to make in
a decentralized way so when you're
engaged in a conflict with another
entity when you're engaged in direct
competition with another entity when you
need to coordinate action beyond the
initial purposes and evolve your
purposes
historically it's been really hard for
decentralized organizations to pull that
off so you want to pick and choose
carefully with respect to
what the dao's purposes are and what its
objectives are and that
should be helpful to the process of
deciding you know how
how do you want to be involved in the
dao and what will it be capable of
accomplishing
so someone in my household may or may
not be me
may have
become somewhat i don't see infatuated
that's not the right word but
obsessed with researching
a lot of the
the kind of nitty gritty aspects of of
daos and
taos i like saying dao just because it
makes me think about like that
right that that
character is actually though in in
mandarin
uh so that's which i think is
metaphorically sort of uh appealing
excellent
branding no questions
but the the in part because
i think of
the fact that not all iterations need to
work right but you will have massive
trial and error over a compressed time
period which which is what gets so
exciting to me because if you want to
create
a new corporate entity structure outside
of c-corp s-corp llc like good luck i
mean it's just going to take you forever
to get there
but in the case of a dao you can really
experiment and
in a sense split test even though it
might be two competing parties trying to
collectively acquire assets let's just
say and there are some that have become
really interesting and really powerful
like flamingo would be an example
and
i don't know if this has been done yet
maybe it has and i'm just getting up to
speed on these things but for instance i
have a foundation
and the foundation funds all sorts of
research into
say psychedelic therapeutics and so on
for different
supposedly intractable psychiatric
conditions although i would i would veto
the intractable part at this point
and it's a real pain in the ass
to deal with the foundation as a tiny
tiny team there's a lot of paperwork
all due respect to lawyers lots of
lawyers lots of hours
lots of filings lots of
to this day
signatures of multiple people if i want
to accept
say donations from other people capital
from other people to fund projects
there are
various types of uh red tape and
headache involved but you know if there
were the potential of bringing people
into a dow
collectively contributing and then
having some type of tax efficient slash
tax deductible
approach to donating to
non-profit ventures
my god that would solve a huge pain
point for me i don't like being the
centralized control point for this right
and i guess that's that's more of a rant
than a question but are there any
particular
experiments that you're looking forward
to seeing or hoping to see in this space
doesn't have to be dao specific but it
could be more broadly speaking
i mean you just named a fascinating one
so
to the extent that one of the things
that these
dow is on i'll use your terminology
sorry i might be corrupting you no no
it's good um that they do is they
facilitate decision making about
assigning assets not only acquisition of
assets but assignment of assets
i'm really fascinated to see which
things they'll succeed in doing really
well and which things they'll do less
well at so take for example you know a
foundation
where you want to do good in the world
but where you want to devote those
assets
is you know a question that reasonable
people could differ
about you know part of it will be would
the people who participated in that
decentralized autonomous organization be
people who shared your world view enough
that you would think that was good so
you know if there are people who if it's
listeners to your podcast and people who
read your books there might be enough
overlap that they would
want to for example
promote psychedelic research which is
having these extraordinary successes
today
i don't know if they would have thought
that 10 years ago when you started doing
this
right or not i mean that's one of the
interesting questions could a collective
be as forward-looking and as willing to
take certain kind of risks as you were
on this issue
we do know that when it comes to
certain kinds of factual questions
crowds do really well so if you ask a
factual question
the collectivity might be great
when it comes to predictive questions
it's a more mixed bag right
if the crowd always did well on that the
markets would always make the correct
predictions they don't always make the
correct predictions
right because
because groups are subject they're
they're human beings behind there and
they're subject to all of the the biases
and uncertainties that are that are out
there you know if the people who bought
into the dao were representative of the
world
you know you might have like a huge
number of people who were adherents to
the chinese communist party and another
large number of people who were deeply
committed believing muslims i'm just
thinking of you know groups that have a
billion more than a billion people you
know and they might fight it out within
the dow about what they want to
invest in and so
you know again i think it's very much
about the purpose and who the
participants are so those are the kinds
of experiments i think that are gonna as
you say in an iterated way show us what
these things are really good at
and show us where these things run into
some of the limitations of human
coordinated behavior
you